so
uh the expectation for the absolute
beginner is that you may know about
python you've heard about it and if you
have that's good it's very popular this
is pi data i assume you've heard about
it but you've heard some things about
python you're interested you want to
make it go fast let's get started so
let's jump in to our first example
because people will often say
that python can be slow
so i'm going to come over here into a
jupiter notebook
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
fake a scientific workload so we're
gonna go apologies we're gonna go real
fast throw your questions and other
things into the chat i'll try to monitor
as best i can um oh the other next talk
is on uh zoom url thank you so much for
telling me that we will go a little bit
over then great
so
what we have here is a fake scientific
workload we're going to use
numpy and we're going to basically
pretend like we're gathering some image
data from some sort of detector from
some sort of sensor we're going to
smooth it so we'll average the input
points and we just have this this for
loop here that's kind of fortran style
it's basically this is some sort of
numeric kind of quantitative method
we're going to run this thing and at the
end of this we'll just pretend like
we're saving something so again this is
fake it's just meant to be illustrative
we're going to run this with numpy with
and with pure python oh let me refresh
right or let me
run this again and this is going to
execute in about 10 seconds and so as
we're just looping through here running
this function gather from detector
creating this fake array we're doing
some smoothing
again just generic python stuff ah gosh
maybe it runs here processing five fake
images in about 10 seconds maybe that's
good enough maybe it's not but the
question is can we make this faster and
our first tool in the toolbox to do so
is we're going to introduce something
called number and number brings us a jit
compiler this means it's going to take
our python code it's going to compile it
we can now get closer to c
c plus plus four tran like speeds we'll
never exceed those but this is still
python and what's really nice about this
i'll go ahead and run this really
quickly while i talk about it what's
really nice about number and it's going
to be a very cursory explanation here
is that
this is a just-in-time compiler so if
you've heard about psython or if you've
looked at some things with c you need to
specify ahead of time what your types
are going to be with number we don't
have to do that because it's just in
time so i wrap this little decorator
this is one convention for using number
around my previous function i don't
change anything else of course also i
import number so i import number i wrap
this little decorator and now when i run
through those same five fake images and
process them
it runs much much faster so we went from
approximately 10 seconds to 700
milliseconds in fact
most of that was compilation time so
when i run this again it's even faster
now that the code has been compiled you
can see we're getting really low latency
so kind of first break right before we
even intro and get into other things hey
if you've got some if you've got some
for loops if you've got some
numpy arrays if you've got some things
where you might want to broadcast a
function across them
number is a really interesting tool to
check out because we can compile our
code we can get c c plus plus for trans
style performance we don't have to we
can do it very very simply for getting
started there's low penalty here for
getting things wrong now number isn't a
uh
applied everywhere they're they're use
cases pro and pro and against um but
just as a quick kind of carrot hey check
this out uh this can be a really useful
tool
uh
with high performance we've got to go
bigger right so we did five images to
continue this example let's do more
let's do 10x the number of images and
when we run this same thing we're gonna
as again these images are fake but meant
to be kind of a realistic example this
takes a little bit more time four
seconds and as we scale this up to 500
we'll see some linear scaling five
seconds to 18 seconds
so we're starting to hit a maybe a bit
more of a performance bottleneck on this
machine on my local machine here where
i'm running this jupyter notebook
so let me jump back
as an example here sorry let me go back
to my slides
so we went through this hey we took our
python code we and i'm sorry i got a
little bit discombobulated but our
number example took us from slower
python code to faster python code now
the reason i'm here the reason i want to
talk to you my name is gus kavanagh i
used to be a consultant i worked on some
data projects small and big i've got a
three-week-old kid so i'm a little bit a
little bit out of it um and what what is
i think what i like or why i'm here is
when i first got started working with
python working with data i struggled uh
with a lot of the tooling that was
around hey i want to analyze some data
i've learned a little bit about let's
say pandas but i'm struggling to
actually get this installed get it get
everything figured out make it actually
work and as an example of this when i
started my first kind of python job
i didn't know what ssh was and so i
would walk to the server room there was
no cloud i walked this about 10 years
ago i would walk to a physical surf room
i would pull the little rack mounted
appliance out and i would work on that
little appliance in the server room no
one else was in there i didn't know any
better and eventually i only learned
that i wasn't supposed to be doing this
my boss was like why aren't you at your
desk you don't have meetings scheduled
what's going on and i was like i'm
working on the server you know they're
like you need to understand you need to
be able to you can remote access the
server so this is when i say for the
absolute beginner now as i'm trying to
intro this talk this is what i mean like
i really i understand there's this
concept like i've got some python i've
got something i can run locally but help
me make this work for me and show me all
of the steps in between don't leave
anything out so that's what we're going
to do and so my kind of expectation here
uh hopefully with that kind of quick
number example to to kind of what your
whistle is
you are interested in pi data the pi
data stack is extremely popular that's
why we're here pandas numpy map plot
label scikit-learn a bunch of other
packages uh but they do struggle a
little bit here
or i'm sorry why do we love why do we
like them they work they're easy most
importantly they are free but we're
gonna hit some of these scaling issues
and we're gonna hit some of these speed
issues so the fir where we want to what
we want to introduce next as we move
into okay i've got a pandas data frame
the next big tool to make this go faster
is going to be rapids so we're going to
go back to our notebook now and we'll
explain what rapids is
and how it works so i'm going to jump
over here for a second to a different
jupiter notebook
this one's actually running in sagemaker
and we'll go through all that a little
bit later but now i've got
my pandas data frame and i'm going to
read in this kind of canonical pseudo
big data data set this new york city
taxi data set everyone's probably super
sick of it we're going to go ahead and
read this in we're going to perform a
group by using pandas and this is going
to take about 20 seconds to run now
again that may be good that may be bad
but we can make this faster and with
rapids what makes rapid so interesting
and exciting is rapids is going to
extend the pi data stack
for the gpu so here i have i import
pandas with pandas convention as pd i
read csv i run a group by it takes 20
seconds or so
let's use a part of the rapids package
called qdf
i import qdf
i run qdf read csv
and i run a very similar identical group
by and this is going to execute much
much faster now oh
memory error how fun let's restart the
kernel so this is this is supposed to be
my next example i've somehow gotten
ahead of myself uh but let's run this
one more time so we
restart this we'll execute our read csv
and so what we're doing and oh my gosh
i'm
[Laughter]
embarrassed
so uh what i wanted to show you was this
was going to execute in about eight
seconds uh and the core idea being that
we'll come back over here very quickly
to some slides the core idea being that
thanks to rapids this package that came
from the good folks at nvidia we can
take our pandas code we can import qdf
and we can run very similar code we'll
also be able to do the same thing for
for numpy for scikit-learn for other
packages uh but i want to show this this
pandas example with codif
however uh what can happen and what will
often happen is you you can get these
memory errors uh specifically because
the the well for one reason because the
gpu memory can be slightly different
than the the cpu memory available on
your machine in my case on my sagemaker
instance
however what i was hoping to show was
that we would get this memory and memory
error with a larger data set
so in this case reading in the single
file this one has about 7 million
records it's not that big at all
the gpu was going to be faster but
significantly faster
meaningfully faster worth the money
faster
questionable so in this case this will
definitely show a memory error when i
read in and forgive the ugly code but
when i read in the entire year's worth
of new york city taxi data which is a
larger data set
so 7 million times 12 84 million records
we hit this memory area error and this
is very common and so
this made me think of like me walking to
the server room like this is the kind of
thing where as a user i would get i get
stuck here
and there are ways of thinking about
how you should profile your code how you
should think about high performance code
you should absolutely read this book uh
by ian oswald and i won't uh pronounce
the other name i've read through the
chapter on number clearly haven't read
the whole thing
but this you this will give you the
actual like hey what's the computer
science approach to this how can i do
this really intelligently what i'm
trying to solve for here is like i'm
getting stuck with this exception what
do i do now and i really want to stay
with just within this basic api don't
make me think too much don't make me
understand too much um and so
what we're hitting at this point is
basically we've got enough data where
even though we have this really fast gpu
now we can do these our compute is just
that's created a memory bottleneck so
let's go back
to our slides really quickly and
basically what we've seen is and this is
you know does not scale gpus will often
lead to memory bottlenecks very similar
with pandas and in fact with that data
set reading in all 84 million rows on my
my small sagemaker instance that too
would have caused
a memory error so
i i will will now say okay great we have
to scale to a larger data set we want to
use the gpu
how do we do this so we started with
i've got some python code i can use
number to compile it to accelerate it
i then went okay well i've got this
pandas data frame what's the best way to
accelerate that something like rapids
qdf runs on the gpu but now i'm stuck
because now it's not fitting in memory
i've got the i've got my compute running
fast but i'm stuck on memory and so if
we go to just a random person on twitter
i don't know this person you know but
from a couple weeks ago or from the late
summer asked what's the best way to read
a 100 gig file you know in the
twitterverse responded read the file in
chunks more ram you should download more
ram don't use python pray know you get
lots of fun responses right and somebody
a very helpful a good samaritan
responded i'd recommend you use desk so
what is desk what is this thing
das is a python package part of the pi
data stack that allows us to scale a
arbitrary python code it has two levels
of api or two two basically interfaces
one is for data frames arrays cycle or
cell estimators and it will scale these
across multiple cores or across multiple
machines in a cluster this is going to
be very helpful for getting us around
our memory bottleneck we'll be able to
more efficiently use all of the cores on
a single machine while the memory on a
single machine or and in this case and
all of the nodes in a cluster which
we'll get to in a second
now desk also has a lower level
interface for more for arbitrary task
scheduling we won't cover that today
but you can do a lot you can build on
this a lot this is foundational for a
lot of other libraries so
what often happens in twitter right you
make a suggestion you try to be helpful
someone's going to shoot you down so
this guy says no no you don't use das
you use pi spark and so as we're now
moving into the dash section of this
this is the the analog you'll see
outside of outside of the python world
is hey use spark use pi spark sure it
runs in the jvm but you have this python
interface
das is very very similar as this person
points out it's also distributed you and
the idea here is it's the familiar api
you're going to be very very close to
the pandas api just as pdf with rapids
is very very close to the pandas api so
that we don't have to learn something
new which again comes back to kind of my
fundamental point of or or motivation
from starting this is keep it please
keep it as simple as possible if i can
run something in pandas help me run this
now faster help me run this with more
data
okay
not just random people at twitter but
real companies organizations use this
walmart has a great example of using
down here at the bottom you can see some
of the logos rapids and dash together to
do
in-store forecasts so they have to do
these 500 million forecasts all these
combinations on year-long horizons it's
this monster problem this big simulation
and what they were able to do with
rapids with desk x2 boost has a native
rapid integration it's able to reduce
this processing time down so they could
get it within a 12-hour window because
it has to be done every day so they
can't get it done in 12 hours it's no
good to them they're able to make this
work i have no idea how this is running
for them with all the supply chain was
late sorry i won't comment this is a
little bit older than that but i think
it's a pretty like a good motivating
example so we've got kind of random
people on twitter saying hey das rapids
you've got companies like walmart hey
das rapids let's put it together and
jump through our example
and while i switch back here i'm just
going to check quickly in the chat
um
okay good so we got some questions about
how easy is it to get number set up
excellent um uh we will get to the setup
here at the end uh or not the end but
after showing this next example with
clusters of machines so i'm gonna switch
from sagemaker now over to google cloud
platform
vertex ai but basically just a hosted
jupyter lab instance running all these
same examples in each environment
locally in the different clouds
and what i want to do now is i want to
install task
and i'm going to use cdf again and this
is that same code we ran before
and we ran this it took you know eight
or nine seconds but we want to run this
with everything and we ran with
everything we got a memory error so how
do we get around that well introduce das
so their desk we can we will install or
we will import excuse me the das
distributed client as well as this local
cuda cluster and the interest of time
i'm not going to explain what this is at
the moment but i'm just going to
instantiate this i'm going to create
this local client
so what this is going to enable us to do
is more efficiently work with the
resources on my in this case client
machine which is this
gpu instance very modest gpu instance in
google cloud it has four cores 16 gigs
of ram and one t4 gpu and i can see that
right here in this local cuda cluster so
i've got my 14 gigs i've got my
i've got my gpu in here inside of it
should be here in this worker here's my
gpu worker tesla t4 which is like a good
combination of performance and cost this
instance i'm running costs something
like 38 cents an hour to run and i'm
paying for this so i want to keep the
cost down
and now i can go ahead and execute the
basically
not basically but very similar code
using das qdf to read csv and perform my
group by now in the interest of time i'm
not going to run this uh but i'll just
show you the wall time from calculated
earlier this now takes three minutes so
let's contrast with previously it was
hey we ran this group by or we're trying
to load all of the data even read the
data in we're getting memory errors cuda
errors hey you don't have enough memory
on your local machine or your client
now we can execute this so this is
probably going to be another good flag
in the ground for a lot of people here
you pip install desk and we'll get into
the installation steps it's relatively
it's very straightforward but you can
use desk locally on your machine on your
local on your your laptop workstation
wherever you are and you're gonna be
able to get around a lot of memory
bottlenecks this is especially useful
for the gpu workflows for using rapids
for using das qdf because it's more
likely that you'll run into those and
with that you'll get around it now three
minutes isn't necessarily barn burner
fast time right like i'm not we're not
lighting it up at three minutes and this
is a pi data talk i've got 30 minutes i
want to be i want this to be fun i want
to be high performance python so let me
show you some examples of using das now
on a distributed cluster so in this
example and i hope this is big enough
i'm sorry
in this in this previous example we had
das running on a local machine now i'm
going to have das running on four
workers
and
i'm going to use a tool i'm going to use
a a piece of software called coil this
is a company i work for coiled i'm a
sales person for coiled so this is not a
coiled sales pitch it's just an easy way
of getting das clusters in the cloud
there are a bunch of other approaches
and i'll cover those at the end uh but
suffice to say once i have this cluster
with my workers on it let's just make
sure this is still up great i've got a
cluster 60 gigs of ram each of these is
composed of essentially my same cpu
client instance for
four virtual cores 16 gigs of ram
uh now i instantiate my dash cluster
just as i did before
and when i execute this it's going to
run much much faster now note here or as
an aside i'm i'm jumping back from the
gpu i should have maybe been a bit more
explicit here i'm just using cpu workers
and i can come over here and take a look
at this and see what's going on
so this is a das dashboard this is
available uh regardless of how you
deploy desk so you're seeing it inside
of the code interface but this is the
same if you run it with a purely open
source you'll have this nice dashboard
you'll be able to see your task stream
here all of these tasks running
across the cores in each of your workers
and this will execute in about two
minutes or so so we're getting we're
getting improved speed up from our
single gpu from running desk on on the
single server from running our local
cuda cluster
but it's still not running as fast as
i'd like for a talk like this like we're
getting better we're getting performance
i could add more workers here i can now
start to linearly scale i could solve
for this problem is like how fast i want
this to run okay how many workers do i
need
i'm getting there but we want to see
what the gpus wants to go even faster so
let's go get a gpu cluster next and i'll
kind of wrap up my code examples here
with the gpu cluster so very similar
again i'm going to use coil but you
could do this with a bunch of other
approaches and rapids does document how
to set all this up
and now with a gpu cluster i have four
workers each of them have the t4 gpu
which is so nice and now we can really
make this thing saying when we execute
this code this will execute about 13
seconds so let me run this jump over
hopefully it isn't finished by the time
i get there
because it's going really really fast
and you can see on the gpu this is going
to execute much much more quickly these
are those same tasks they're just flying
through
and in the dash dashboard there's a ton
we can do here to zoom in and try to
better understand we've got to zoom in
even further oh my goodness do we zoom
in on as to actually what is taking what
amount of time this is a whole kind of
talk in itself
but we'll be able to see and i should
zoom in further to show you exactly
which steps you can see the time here um
so
i want to pause there for a second and
i'll double and i'm going to take a
quick look at the chat
but what we've shown is we've taken this
same
workflow we started with
running on
running on a our local machine or
running locally using pandas we hit it
we realized we we hit a memory error
same thing we used our our wrap our gpu
gosh the gpu is so fast but to get the
full data set we needed we needed to get
around a local memory bottleneck
installing desk and running desk excuse
me not there running desk on a
local dash cluster helped us get around
this it was a little bit slower than
maybe i
personally would have liked but i solved
this i'm now using rapids i'm using a
gpu i'm doing it with a pandas-like data
frame this is very similar syntax read
csv group buy i don't have to learn a
new api and then i'm able to process
this data i'm able to get a big
performance speed up
this is very very exciting for me i like
this this is probably where you could
stop if you want additional performance
you want to go even faster you can
distribute this out exact same syntax
with desk onto a cluster we could do
this on a cpu cluster and it ran in
about a minute 30 a minute 20 very
similar code read the csv group by and
we could go even faster on a gpu cluster
and again the code the important thing
here is our code doesn't change whether
it's local cluster or distributed it's
the exact same thing it's just this dash
code desk udf read csv
so if you if you haven't checked out
like benz zeitlin's talk or all the
stuff that the nvidia folks have been
doing here you really should but
hopefully this is like motivating enough
hey i can use a little bit of number to
compile some compile my python
especially for loops numpy stuff
broadcast functions do that if you have
data frames
you really want to look at rapids qdf
and you can use das distribute that
across clusters
let's talk a little bit now about how
this all gets installed and how this
gets
set up
so i will show that
here and i'm going to try to wrap this
up maybe i guess since i have an extra
minute or two i'm going to wrap this up
in the next five minutes
so
real quick on setup is uh and i'll just
show it directly from the different
cloud tools
to use rapids they have this this
wonderful guide and they'll explain
where you can get things and how to set
things up in the cloud uh and this isn't
specific to the company i work for
anything like that it's just for aws
azure gcp
but what i've found to be the easiest
approach per cloud is to use their
hosted ml service so if you go into
sagemaker you can create notebook
instances and jump directly into jupiter
lab and here i just created a g4 dnxl so
this is about 75 cents an hour it's four
cores one t4
i don't have i don't pay for a very
expensive instance here because i'm
going to use something else coiled to
scale out when i need clusters of gpu
workers or clusters of cpu workers this
helps me keep my costs down
but in this case i create this notebook
instance
and then when i'm inside of jupiter lab
here it's very easy to get everything
installed because rapids gives us this
quick start which is is really really
impressive so i click over here on get
started
and they give you this little release
guide and so this is exactly what i
follow and you can choose between what
version you want what version of python
what version of cuda and what's nice
about sagemaker here in this case is
they give us all the things that we need
so if you try to install this yourself
which you could if you had a local gpu
but you'll need to install cuda this
comes pre-installed you just don't have
to worry about it so intentionally like
not giving details here because just
like this becomes a solved problem
gcp has a very similar offering
this is called vertex ai they keep
changing the name it looks like it's
about half the price of sagemaker which
i find very nice and i create the same
instance four cores 15 gigs of ram and
then it's in jupiter lab once again and
then we're just copying and pasting this
example
and then finally in terms of getting
things installed so hopefully this ends
hopefully this is like hey if i can run
one contact command i can get everything
installed this rapids package includes
desk it includes number includes all of
this stuff you could also just pip
install them directly but it can get a
little bit tricky this is where i should
have prefaced this beginning this is
really where rapids as a package shines
it gives you cootie it gives you all of
the stuff all of it works
finally if you want to do this on your
clusters docker is a great tool for this
you don't have to learn docker
they will give you this docker command a
pre-built container image and then what
i did with coiled here just for complete
you know for completeness when i created
these clusters i specified
what uh image i wanted to use there's a
facility within coil for doing this
that's a docker image but this also
works for other tools for deploying desk
and i'll talk about that here in a
second um but so basically for getting
set up locally uh
this is it's it's use rapids and it's
going to be very straightforward then
we've got a great question in the chat
which is like hey can i wait can i use
number jet can i use number with desk
and the answer is yes absolutely
so that will be my that was this should
be my
concluding example here so i've got my
oh
let's just restart this
uh yes you can combine them and the
reason i spent more time on qdf than on
working with numba and i apologize if
that was if that led some folks
australian from my from my uh agenda
was the i was kind of blown away by just
the completeness with qdf how easy it is
to get started and how when you use that
you can scale this out very nicely
number when we're going to run on the
gpu is going to involve a slightly
different api than running on the cpu
and that was a change i don't know how
recently this change occurred but from a
previous version of this code that i'd
run with like number like 0.48 it didn't
involve this api change and i'll be
honest it kind of walked me in the head
so but yes our code will run here this
will this will work um
and let's
sorry i have to make sure i have the
right cluster
let's get that
existing
uh cpu example v2
all right let's get our client object
and i i may not have enough time here to
show this but the short answer is yes it
can and so in this case i have that same
number jit that same code we've wrapped
our existing code with number and then
we can submit it to our das cluster and
here uh previously you just saw like das
qdf you just saw data frame it was a
pandas-like thing here we're using the
lower level interface that i mentioned
at the very beginning when i introduced
ask this is das con
futures interface it's very similar to
python 3's concurrent futures and so now
i can submit arbitrary tasks and tasks i
can submit each of these functions
and in so doing i can now start to see
linear speed up here so we can we can
take that compiled code we can send it
to the schedule we can send it across
our workers and we can see linear
speedups across our dash cluster so yes
this does work very very well and this
also works number is is absolutely
compatible with with cuda with running
on the gpus there's just a slight
adjustment in terms of setting some
initial variables that has me as again
as a very basic beginner type user
somebody who was walking into a server
room versus using an ssh client a little
bit stymied at the moment um
to do
okay
all right so let's wrap this let me wrap
this up with uh deployment options and
i'll jump back and show this from slides
uh just to keep this
a little bit cleaner
um so in wrapping this up you can deploy
desk a bunch of different ways uh das
can be installed manually there's
excellent documentation i have links to
all of this it's just a cli command
there is a tool for running desk on your
cloud provider aws azure gcp and a few
others this tool is called das cloud
provider it's open source you can go
ahead and use it you can also deploy
desk on kubernetes and so if you had a
cluster of machines you could now say
great if i've got a cluster of gpu
workers i can use das kubernetes i could
use that cloud provider i need to use a
an image or two from rapids to make sure
i have my dependencies but that's your
pattern there are also commercial
offerings uh three in particular coiled
where i work in sales uh saturn cloud
also offers they're very much a
competitor they offer das clusters as a
service you know hassle-free dash
clusters
and then in terms of the major cloud
offerings there isn't a aws or azure
desk offering yet but google
data proc which is oops i'm sorry google
dataproc which is their spark cluster as
a service it has a dat uses an open
source dash package called bask yarn
to deploy desk
your mileage may vary with that but it
is an option obviously i'm heavily
biased towards coil because i work there
a quick recap on costs and then i think
we'll i'll wrap this up as i know i keep
saying i will so i'm running the initial
the client
you saw sagemaker you saw google cloud
uh you would see azure but i'm
getting some quota issues and it's just
a little too expensive i think for this
for for the budget i was trying to set
for this um so here are the costs
factoring in the clusters i got from
coiled this case 38 cents for the hour
of my gcp notebook and then 81 cents for
my gpu cluster and then similarly for
aws 75 cents for an hour of my stage
maker notebook and 81 cents for my gpu
cluster about half the cost excuse me
for the um for the cpu cluster so the
nice thing here again however you choose
to deploy ephemeral dash clusters you'll
if you're running these in the cloud
we'd highly encourage you only run them
when you actually are executing your
code when you're thinking about things
you're sipping coffee when you're
hanging out and just mulling over your
problem use a much less expensive uh
client
oh and before uh before i'm gonna skip
comparisons actually and say
the final bit of this that's i think
that's exciting is a relatively recent
python package
eric welch and james berbeau just
recently put out
and this is a tool called afar so
if you don't want to use a gpu client if
you don't want to if you don't have a
gpu on your local machine if you don't
want to install rapids on your local
machine if you don't want to bother
setting up a sagemaker notebook a gcp
notebook or an azure ml compute instance
you actually can run all these things
from a local machine thanks to this new
package called afar this is really
really cool it's very new so it's still
from for me personally i still tend to
use one of these gpu clients to get to
make things easier but i all i have to
do now to have here back on my local
machine local host i can import afar
and with this little you know with
statement i can now apply
i can run remotely submit this code to
my das cluster we'll come back over you
can see this on the gpu example this
code is going to be executing here on my
gpu cluster and i'm doing this from a
local machine where i don't have it i
don't have a gpu on my macbook i don't
have cuda installed i don't have to
worry about those dependencies i can
work with a das cluster afar
so big thank you to eric big thank you
to james we'll be looking for more from
this package again i think you'll
probably still find it useful to have
some local gpu client it may even save
you money if you're only doing if you
have smaller data sets or if those
longer times are
are acceptable um but now you could say
okay hey i could use a remote cluster
from somebody like coiled or saturn
cloud or something else or desk cloud
provider and i can do i can work from my
local machine directly with that cluster
without having to set up this
intermediate client
okay
so there i will pause now i'll stop
sharing um i hope we're not too i'm 20
minutes over
my apologies um
there are a bunch of great tutorials on
desk on them yeah i i don't think there
are any other questions in the chat um
thank you all for for listening and uh
for showing up